let's go do something gnarly and then
reboot everything so then we can start
to truly showcase the basics again
on the Pod today are three guys
attempting a most impressive and
meaningful feat so could we skydiver
base jump land and run a full marathon
and then plunge into the water or Swim
on all seven continents in seven days
my friend my coach frequent podcast
guest Chris houth is one of them the
other two are former Navy SEAL Ryan
Birdman parrot as well as former U.S
army Special Forces Alex Bracey together
they're all here to discuss this insane
crazy impending uh feat that they're
about to Embark upon it's called the 7x
project we gotta go big and maybe I went
a little too far or maybe a lot too far
but more impressive than the actual feed
itself is the goal behind it which is to
gather data on human performance and
more importantly recovery from high
stress situations for the purpose of
helping retired veterans learn how to
recover properly from the traumas they
endured throughout a career of selfless
service we've never been at War like
this for decades at a time so there are
people out there that maybe just missed
it as far as hey this there's some
really simple things you can do to take
better care of yourself just focusing on
how you eat sleep move and even mindset
stuff right on top of all of this they
also hope to shed a light on and find a
solution for a silent epidemic in our
country which is that five times more
veterans have died by Suicide since 9 11
and have died in combat or in active
duty in any form which is obviously a
huge problem in dire need of redress
and so yeah it's a massive problem and
that's just that community and talk
about First Responders and you talk
about civilians
who knows what that number looks like
so this conversation we unpack a lot
it's equal parts inspiring and important
and I'm honored to share it with you all
right now so please hit that subscribe
button and enjoy
so happy to have you guys here uh really
excited to get into all of this the uh
the how the why but let's start with the
what like who wants to jump in and
explain this crazy [ __ ] thing that
you guys are about to do right now
uh I'm gay men so uh the back story of
this event is
I've always been fascinated by extreme
sports and so doing things like
skydiving base jumping Flying Wing suits
anything that gets my heart rate going
I've been fascinated by and I've been
doing it but I wanted to do it in a way
that would not only honor veterans for
their service but also be able to give
back to them so how do we raise Capital
well we do crazy things and then it
brings money and then we give that away
and in 2019 I got a phone call from a
teammate that my sniper partner my one
of my True North in life took his life
and for me it was
I don't like when people say that sucks
or I'm just gonna mourn them I want to
do something about it and so I said what
are we missing here why does this keep
happening I'm so sick to death of losing
friends
so for me it was is there more to the
story than it just being a brain issue
and my idea was that it was
physiologically based because everything
is part of the physiology and if it's
not all in unison you're going to have
problems take a guy like Alex who's done
25 years in the military if you compound
that effect of breaking them down over
that career of course they're going to
have issues when they get out so then my
idea was all right let's go do something
gnarly and break our anatomy break our
physiology and then reboot everything so
then we can start to truly showcase the
basics again how do you get back to True
North or homeostasis
so the idea of coming up with 7x was
going to care if we run in Six States or
seven you know cities or whatever we
gotta go big and after meeting Chris and
doing some of these runs I'm like maybe
I went a little too far or maybe a lot
too far
Chris has experience with that though he
has overly eager and enthusiastic out
athletes that approach him with
audacious projects and he has a very
delicate touch in trying to you know
kind of create a sense of reality around
that but you know obviously you're here
and this is happening so it is and so
the idea was could we do like the seal
thing sorry
but see Aaron land so could we skydiver
base jump land and run a full marathon
and then plunge into the water or Swim
on all seven continents in seven days
and I immediately asked some of my dear
friends like Alex hey what do you think
about this and it was instantaneously
I'm in and so we knew that we had a
caliber of um guys who had the mentality
for it who were willing to get to the
athletic place they needed to be and
then we started developing the team the
scientist team around it to say what are
we going to study how are we going to do
this thing
and everything we thought of except for
like are we gonna get coached like who's
going to teach us how to move this way
and Alex actually spearheaded finding us
Chris
right so you're you're you're part of
your profession Alex is as a coach right
as a sort of performance coach yeah at
large yeah yep I do some personal
performance coaching but you know try to
get in from an athletic standpoint not
at this level so
um actually I mean you know starting
with the CL army stuff where we bust
each other's chops all the time
um
the only reason I'm at the podcast is
because I've heard about him through
your book so I read your book and I was
like
you know went from the couch to doing
what
he did
um and I had to go back because it was
on Audible I had to listen to the I'd
listen already and I was like what's
that coach's name what's his company and
then I uh I did the cold email off of
the website and got a call back and here
we are right a few months later so right
yeah so I found I found Chris through
you your story illuminated you know I
knew enough about zone two to know that
we needed somebody who could
with an endurance get us there yeah you
know as opposed to the whole running and
the gray Zone
the whole time and then being like wow
we really tanked on the actual event
yeah so there's the actual endurance
piece to this whole thing running seven
marathons on seven continents in seven
days and we'll get into you know where
those locations are and what that
entails and then there's the extreme
piece to this whole
thing which is base jumping into these
marathons or parachuting into them and
then there's the logistics piece right
which I'm sure you guys are really good
at like this is kind of what you're
trained at so it's a very complicated
puzzle right it's a nightmare yeah it's
a yes it's a [ __ ] nightmare so the
idea behind how do we how are we going
to pull this off is my co is a Green
Beret and my personal belief is that
Green Berets are the best at Logistics
they're good at going into places and
establishing a relationship establishing
like a mechanism within that place and
so not only do we bring the Green Beret
and Bryce Hanson to actually run the
logistics piece but then he brought in
his Green Beret team to deploy around
the world to really get these locations
fortified connect with the locals make
sure that we were set with everything so
it's been a process of about
15 months of planning and we're about 80
percent there right now okay so explain
the locations and the specifics of the
event itself just so people understand
what we're talking about here certainly
so we're taking a group of about 75 to
80 people on this so that alone right we
made the list first called me and he
told me this I was like wait what
exactly how many Runners are there go
ahead so they don't know that they're
all doing it too so that was that was
another question I had but go ahead so
um so we'll all fly into Cape Town South
Africa where we stage and that's where
our plane will be waiting for us we have
a 757 this is not like a little it's a
massive plane right apparently it seats
400 people so we went Overkill and it's
just one of those things that can get us
everywhere we need to go
um it's quite expensive too so I would
imagine just the drama of trying to find
the plane that we could actually use
that was available
that was somewhat within reason of cost
uh that was difficult enough just to
find a plane
so we actually worked on that for about
nine months to get a plane solidified
so once we get to Cape Town we'll get on
our plane we'll stay on that plane for
the duration of the trip and we go right
from Cape Town into a place called White
desert Antarctica very private place
really really cool place this white Dash
desert.com and you can actually go there
but it's um
it's very desolate there's not much
there so our VIPs are going with us are
going to be doing like ice wall climbing
and apparently one of the packages they
get is they get to have a snowball fight
with the Special Operations afterwards
which is really why everybody wants to
go
um is this where people have gone in the
past to do their Antarctica Marathon or
this is a different part of Antarctica
this is completely different yeah so
this is Runway ice Runway this is going
to be our location to run around several
times
but it's really cool they have pods they
have kitchen they have warm rooms they
have everything that we need should we
have an issue there so because weather
changes pretty quickly and if we can't
get out and we're in trouble so we're
gonna try to make it as quick as
possible
uh so what will happen is when we land
in Antarctica we're going to start off
by doing a Skydive and the Skydive the
second we leave the plane is when it
kicks off the seven days so we could be
there for 10 hours and not be part of
the seven days it's when we leap starts
the seven day women
so we'll do our deal it's going to take
him two hours to complete the marathon
it's going to take us 12. so we're gonna
get it done has anybody uh uh parachuted
into Antarctica before yes they have yes
yeah that's we're not trying I mean what
we are doing with this specific event
altogether it's not a world record
because it's never been done so it just
doesn't exist right but that's not our
vision here our vision is we want
answers we want to really build
something at the end we'll talk about it
later but build something at the end
that we can give to people to truly help
benefit their life so it's Uncharted
Territory so we'll do our jump and then
we're gonna get right into the run we're
still working out what that's going to
look like and then we're going to plunge
we're going to pull our plunge we have
those glacial legs out there so they're
gonna pounce pound some of that out and
we're gonna jump in how long do you
think you're gonna be going in that
water uh three minutes minimum but I'm
gonna try to push four yeah nice that's
cool do you do you parachute with your
running shoes on and just immediately go
into the run or do you assess when you
land yeah we're gonna actually be in
cold cold weather gear for the jump it's
going to be super cold way up high and
we're not sure exactly what the altitude
we're gonna jump at but way too cold for
us to go slick so we're going to have
time when we land to change out get
ready and then start warming up because
one of the biggest complexities with
jumping especially in areas like this
and wind is you can turn an ankle or any
really quickly upon landing and if you
do that it's over there's no getting
into the run right your host and your
host for the whole trip so we got to be
very careful about how we do our
Landings not just in that type of
environment but because we're going to
be tired muscle is going to be
completely smoked after each day the
jumps are going to get more and more
detailed they're going to be more
complex so we have to really be careful
about that and do you jump from a
separate aircraft or are you you're not
jumping out of a 757 right like that
doesn't that would be
so yeah but you must have some other
aircraft for that right it would be a
normal what most jumpers we jump out of
twin otters so we'll be jumping out of a
Skydive plane out there got it okay and
there's there's four total
um veterans that are actually doing the
challenge is that correct so there's
seven in total four veterans seven in
total that are going to be doing all of
the running and then four of the seven
will be doing the Skydive run and plunge
got it okay and then the rest of the
plane is filled with
um support team I mean on your website
you have this massive team like there's
a lot of people that are contributing to
this effort but then on top of that you
have uh like VIPs right who are kind of
donating money or paying for the
privilege of being on the plane for part
or all of this endeavor
yes correct every time we go into a
little deeper Mission planning we find
that oh we need this or we need this and
we want to be self-sustaining so we have
our medical professionals on the team we
have support staff for our team for the
VIPs because we're going to go separate
directions the VIPs get to actually run
a mile with us on each continent they
get a tandem skydive over the pyramids
of Egypt I mean they get to do some
really cool things but then they're off
to do a very personalized Excursion
while we're completing each Mission I
see cool yeah so we'll have nutrition
support we'll have physical therapy you
know PT support we'll have our doc team
and our emergency medical technician
um you know on the ground we need to
stick this guy with an IV Patrick will
be with us on on our part of the
adventure
um and all of the admin piece of you
know feeding us and just you know being
able to react to anything that happens
some of the runs will be laps others
will be out and back so they'll be
different admin requirements for all of
that and you know even just uh
you know running in Antarctica we're
going to make a good guess at what we
should be wearing but
right luckily a few miles later if we've
completely boogered that up we'll be
able to
have have yeah you know have what we
need right there with our team to fix it
well the good news is you have a massive
plane that can handle a lot of equipment
right whatever we want it so don't worry
about how many bags you're bringing with
you exactly there's that but it's also I
mean um knowing what we're getting into
and trying to pre-plan that but I think
the bigger story is around all these
participants too from from the logistics
standpoint they're part of the
experience to then help in the
documentary and sort of the information
we're gleaning from it that they're
there first hand to also provide
valuable you know professional Insight
right and we'll get into all of that in
the why but I just want to walk through
like the experience itself so from
Antarctica you go where we go to Perth
Australia so we chose the most well I
should say this because I'll take
ownership I've chosen the worst scenario
of travel so everybody World Marathon
challenge all those other organizations
that do things like this they're like
why are you going that way yeah what do
you mean am I wrong so it just looked
good to me so we're going fast backwards
but we're going to Perth next so that's
a nice long leg for us to do some
recovery see how we feel after the first
one and then we're going to start
thawing out Midway through and then we
get the Australian it's gonna be hot so
we go from super cold Sub-Zero
temperature all the way to super hot
summertime so that's going to be
interesting in itself we chose Perth um
and really I chose some of these
locations because of the at the
beginning planning of this we were still
heavily in coveted and so some of these
places were locked down or it was an
impossibility there was one point where
I said this is not even going to be able
to happen because Australia was locked
down completely
and we were I mean we brought in State
Department reps and other entities to
help us figure out how to circumnavigate
and I mean they're like we'll do
everything in our power but we can't
guarantee anything so I'm like we don't
have a program here so it got really
nerve-wracking but we just kept pushing
forward and then finally you started
seeing things open up it was a blessing
so Australia would be next one of our
Pro base jumper skydivers from Australia
so we've got major connectivity out
there we're connected to Australian SAS
so they're going to lay out a lot of the
red carpet and we're choosing more of an
area that's more desolate kind of looks
like Australia as far as instead of city
I'm just I don't like
spiders much so I'm kind of that's gonna
be my thing in this whole trip like if I
see a spider you'll hear me a million
miles away well there's lots of stuff in
Australia that wants to kill you spiders
concerned me though
but you're gonna base jump into the
marathon from there uh let's see so in
Australia we're also skydiving I see so
there was only a couple places we
actually originally wanted to do base
jumping everywhere but it's impossible
to do base jumping in seven days on
Seven Continents it's just too hard so
skydiving's a lot easier everybody on
the team skydives had very few base jump
so we wanted to make sure that everybody
who was jumping could truly jump so Alex
and some of our other guys did military
jumps and it converts over
um and our pro athletes are some of the
best jumpers in the world so Scott
having we're only doing base jumping in
two or three locations okay of the seven
right but those are epic locations so
from Perth you go where's next from
there to Dubai Dubai so there's an epic
base jump happening there so it was it
was originally gonna we were looking at
the uh the AL Burge and we heard that it
was feasible but for a price tag that we
couldn't afford right so that's the
first Khalifa that the the tallest
building there no it's the one on the
water the tall one oh definitely an
extra sale one correct yeah okay yeah
it's got the helicopter platform
um but we've now gotten word that it's
uh the princess Tower so you I mean you
can jump a wingsuit outfit so I'm
thinking Hmm maybe we're gonna do
wingsuits hmm so that'll be a base jump
but everywhere will still contain a
Skydive as well let's put the guys that
are hot base jumpers we can still get
that going I mean how many can do the
wingsuit you thought you do that right
does anyone else on the team do it I
mean you have coaches and stuff like
that but of the people that are running
the marathons
right so yeah I should look at that and
say am I doing something wrong with my
life I know
that was by the way my wife is obsessed
with with like bird suit flying like
she's constantly sharing those videos
like she's just like in a I think you
know in some parallel universe she's
like a a you know a bird suit person
like she just loves it like it's
fantastic it's such a cool I want to get
into like what that's all about but I
don't want to derail what we're talking
about sorry for the diversion absolutely
so it's neat Dubai really cool place and
for me I mean he's traveled everywhere
around the world I spent most of my time
in Iraq so I haven't seen the world like
he has I have never been to any one of
these locations minus London so I'm
really excited it's going to be new
um yeah so we go to Dubai and after we
complete the jump then we're going to
run I think that they've considered the
marathon that they do out there the
marathon route and then we'll Plunge in
the water and get back to our plane and
we're out to the next location which
would then be Cairo Egypt um
that one's gonna be fun yeah so you're
gonna parachute over the Great Pyramids
that's right there has to be some
logistical back channeling with
political bigwigs in order to pull that
off right no one gets to do that it's
hard it's been difficult and yeah sign
this paper and then submit it and we'll
tell you in three weeks if you're good
to go or not it's been a lot longer than
three weeks so we're still working
through it
um but it happens we've you know plenty
of our guys have jumped it before so not
really worried about it
um it's gonna be an interesting Marathon
because some of it's off sand takes me
back to the days of Seal training which
sucked so running in soft sand is not
the most fun so it won't be all soft
sand
um and then we actually have to get into
helicopter or we're going to get into a
plane and fly to a different location
and jump in the water because the Nile's
really really bad there's a lot of
bacteria in there and apparently
Americans are not allowed at all to go
in the water so and what is the swim
piece in all of this so what does that
of me getting in the water yeah so of
course the athletes always ask that
question where everybody else like oh
you're gonna get in the water so yeah it
was just a plunge and the idea for me
was Sierra and land so let's just get in
the water because I didn't think we were
going to have enough time to actually do
a swim on each location it's more so
just Dash yourself off from the marathon
and enjoy so right yeah that was my
first question when bird brought this up
I was like when you say swim what do you
mean because that's a significant
emotional event for some army guys right
right so I mean there's a reason you
went into the army as long as I went in
the army that is absolutely true Navy
Army yeah so uh he was like ah just a
plunge man I was like all right I'm good
with that right I'm looking forward to
swimming yes of course you are yeah I'm
looking forward to watching Chris you're
gonna have some lawn chairs parked right
at the base
you all plunge Chris is going to go on a
little mini adventure of his own right
again unique locations when else am I
going to have a chance to do those swims
and Chris are you going to run all the
marathons also run all the marathons and
we have two Pacers along
um guys who run Ultras and so on so
friends of theirs and they've been
around them for a while but then when we
were about a month into the coaching six
weeks into the coaching they said we'd
love to have you along and I was like
well all right twist my arm yeah so
although you know you go through the
training and you're like yeah Marathon
for seven days in a row is gonna be a
little painful it's a little bit you
know you're no stranger to these things
though I am not but this is a little
qualitatively different right base
jumping are you gonna jump I'm uh tandem
jumping in um Egypt that's right you are
one of the pyramids it's at a minimum
yeah we'll see
just you're gonna just push Chris out
the door right absolutely and we're
gonna get it on camera too they've
already said they've already said a few
times the fact that I've put them
through this training Peaks torture
they're like we're gonna get it all back
yeah one in one single day out that
window we'll catch you we'll catch you
but as your free fall and release the
shoot right
um all right so from Egypt then to to
London to London yeah and here's here's
where it gets pretty cool right I'm
super excited about London because I
believe personally that I'm James Bond
so I'm super excited to go back to my
homeland so uh-huh now London was uh
just one of those deals where I'd work
with some of the British SAS and I've
got a lot of friends out there I said
this was going to be a really unique
place for us to go
um initially we worked on jumping the
bridge out there and the bridge is very
unique it's called London Bridge and a
lot of people know it significant what
people don't know is it was the place
where they first did base jumps and it
was like in the 1800s like late 1800s
for military testing so it has been
jumped once since then and it's very
difficult to get done well one of our
guys on our team is friends with a guy
who makes all that happen so we said all
right let's go for that and then we were
going to jump into the water so we would
actually land run the full Marathon
first and then jump off the bridge into
the water we have had since then had to
change it because getting a parachute
wet and salt water it really taxes your
parachute we can't use the rest of the
trip so the idea now is we're actually
going to
land and we're going to run our marathon
and then what will happen is at Chelsea
Hospital we're going to park a crane and
we're going to base jump off the crane
right near Chelsea hospital and there's
water right there for the skydivers they
will go on a helicopter to a new
location and make their jump and then
we'll all come back together wow that's
cool yeah that's a bummer though they
won't let you do it off the bridge
well they'll let them do it it's just
because of this oh because of the shoot
right yeah okay yeah gotcha we are still
working on it you know we're just going
to keep going until they say absolutely
no because you get a different shoot
it just becomes more money yeah I mean
you got a 757 I mean you're gone you
know you might as well go the extra mile
exactly
oh this is logistics yeah
um wow cool and uh and then from there
Cartagena Cartagena and that's the last
stop
uh the last stop will be America oh
America oh that's right yeah okay so
sorry walk us through the last two yeah
so we want to go to uh cardhania
originally it was going to be Brazil we
chose Cartagena because it's closer gets
us into town we can do what we need to
do and then it's a shorter stunt from
where we're going in Columbia to America
so that we could get on the ground and
rest for a bit and acclimatize before we
start moving
so we chose cartania and it's really
nice because they're super about working
with us you know we've partnered with
the Colombian Navy they're offering an
experience of a lifetime to our VIPs
rather than go out and shoot fully
automatic machine guns off their boats
at Targets and just metal targets and
plastic targets and things like that but
it's something that they don't offer to
anybody so that's what we're looking for
what the VIP experience was could we do
things that you can't pay to do period
it's things that we're using our
connections and our friendships to say
we're doing something unique and this is
for the greater good what can we really
do because these these VIPs are
benefactors they're the ones who are
making this whole thing happen right for
us so we're showing them an incredible
experience wow we are almost dying so
yeah you guys are gonna be fine you're
in good hands with Chris you're gonna be
all right yeah I don't know about the
shoot not opening up or anything Chris
can't help you with that part but the
Running part I think you guys aren't
going to be good if he twisted his ankle
upon Landing he would still run faster
than us yeah
um we're gonna get into the training
don't worry uh all right and then you
end up at
um at a uh in in the United States at
like the SEAL Museum right so we're
initially trying for that and we ended
up deviating to Texas now we're gonna go
just near uh Dallas Texas so it brings
everybody back to where we're originally
starting from we can bring all our gear
back and then after we finish we're
gonna have you know a couple days of r r
and enjoyment with families and that and
then we've got brain scans for the
athletes so we partner with the center
for brain health and they're doing pre
and post brain scans just to see what
happens when somebody goes through
something like this yeah so be able to
quantify some data because one thing is
we focus on physiology they focus really
on the brain so let's bring it all
together
Julie what would you say to somebody who
comes to you and says you know what I
find your lifestyle or the way that you
eat really aspirational but I'm too busy
I just don't have time I don't want to
be cracking open cookbooks and trying to
learn a new skill when I'm already
exhausted after a long day how do you
guide this person where should they go
the plant power meal planner is really
really such an amazing value it is under
two dollars a week and for that it gives
you this inspiration know-how and
thousands of recipes to create the
plant-based meals that you crave in your
own life so it's so amazing to be able
to log on to the plant power meal
planner and get the recipes the
ingredients the shopping list and then
the support from all of the coaches that
we have available to answer all of your
questions so join us in eating more
healthy vibrant plant plant-based meals
and to kick start our health intentions
this New Year we're offering you twenty
dollars off a one-year membership with
the code power20 throughout the entire
month of January to learn more and to
sign up go to
meals.richroll.com again that's promo
code power 20 for 20 off at meals Dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
while he gets a pretty good segue into
the why behind all of this I mean you
shared a little bit about
your background and and uh and your
colleague who who took his life uh I
know veteran Health mental emotional
physical spiritual is really the
backbone of this whole thing so you know
talk to talk to me about you know the
inspiration for this and
um you know maybe even contextualize it
with
uh some sense of of you know what's
going on with veterans right now what
the problems are and how you are looking
at the solutions to these problems
absolutely I love the tag team this one
with you sure yeah let's do it so Alex
more on the mic here yeah so
it would be when I
David Metcalf is my sniper partner's
name and it would be like me and Alex
Alex is a leader he was higher ranking
than me and he's a guy that everybody
around him looks at as hey you're the
go-to guy because you're always on point
you're always ready to go you're the guy
who looked too for good word and advice
so that was David for me and
we have this suicide epidemic and it's
not just the veteran Community it's
across the globe it's an issue a
terrible issue
but you never think about your Mentor
your true north taking their life you
feel completely helpless when that
happens and that's what I felt I mean I
felt like I was I had no guidance at
that point and then I couldn't
understand why he of all people did it
because this is not David some people
say that David was the guy that we all
went to and we never saw it his wife
didn't see it I mean there's nothing up
until the very end mm-hmm and we've been
dealing more and more with the
post-traumatic stress of the wars the
tbis traumatic brain injuries you're
hearing about CTE within the NFL and
that and so it's becoming a bigger
problem personal take as we've talked
about it what we try to understand and
try to take our minds to where that
could be to better understand it because
it's hard
and I've been low before I've had my my
dealings with depression and anxiety and
I didn't get to that point where that
was a thought so I'm trying to get there
for David's sake and for all the others
and
one is being away from the tribe that's
a humongous thing you know you're part
of something I was eight years in I did
eight years in the military
25 years you've been in athletics your
whole life and then let's say that you
can't be around that Community anymore
you know how does that make you feel
what do you do and it's not easy to get
through it you got to figure out who you
are deeper and we're not trained to do
that we don't talk about that stuff
we're supposed to be tough right we tell
ourselves that
so being part of the community is
something that we're trying to teach
people is hey you got to stay connected
with the Brotherhood The Sisterhood you
have to stay involved even though you
don't wear the uniform because it's not
the uniform it's the camaraderie that's
what matters and what builds us to do
the jobs we do
um
so that's one of the biggest pieces the
second piece is
they don't try to reinvent themselves
you know it's that don't we don't want
people to live in the past you got to
move forward and you're going to say
okay I still am that person but I want
to add to it now so what's next for me
and I'm gonna go for it
um what are your thoughts on that yeah I
think I think um to just add on to what
Birdman said and I've been out of the
military since 2016 so
my experience is way different than what
people leaving the military now are
experiencing and I hope they're
experiencing a much better transition
um than what was going on back when I
when I got out and I had a great
transition but I don't know that it was
you know my unit did as much as you know
we were always kind of on The Cutting
Edge of how do we just get better at
everything whether that was
performance while you're in the job
to hey we need transition guys out
better and gals out better and we're
always just trying to learn
as I think about everything that we're
talking about I'm I'm fortunate in that
I've never had someone very close to me
from the military commit suicide
um
and I try to think about you know how do
people get to that spot and I just you
know obviously anybody sitting here
talking about it can't
can't really relate to that or at least
in my mind they can't
um
what I've been thinking about a lot as
part of this
project and the you know the things
we're trying to help
our community with and it you know and
that's firefighters police officers you
know people in the medical field that
just have these incredibly stressful
situations that generally people you
know a lot of people in their common
day-to-day life don't experience like
the military so so I would you know I
kind of look at that whole group as our
as our community that we want to be able
to help affect mainly
um I keep coming back to Transitions and
relationships and
I'm fortunate and that I've I have I had
great you know my big thing was I love
the people I worked with and I was in
the same organization for over 17 years
last 17 plus years of my career was with
the same people and and I'm you know
it's I mean it's they're your family you
know some years I spent more time with
them than I did my My Wife and Kids my
biological family so
so it is it's interesting to think about
how that can affect
certain people when they when they lose
that when they lose that identity you
know you put all your eggs in one basket
hey I'm a I'm a
I'm an army Special Forces Stud I'm a
Navy SEAL I'm a marsac guy I'm I'm I'm a
SWAT operator I'm a you know I'm the
whatever the best firefighter in my
county and then all of a sudden you lose
that or you just
age out right
um
how does that affect people and how do
we like like Birdman was saying how do
we how do we maybe focus on keeping
people from Ever Getting to that
spot where they think of like think
about that as an option because I don't
you know I don't know who's ever going
to figure out how to
fix the while I'm already here
but you know
I like walking them off the ledge versus
like preventing them from even getting
yeah
let's just keep them off you know away
from the cliff together it's uh you know
it's a great it's a great point and it's
a much more complicated conversation
about how you solve that connection
piece than it is to talk about TBI or
PTSD like I feel like
um you know we've we have come a long
way in terms of awareness of these
issues I don't know how great you know
the Veterans Administration is or or
what the care looks like for you know
people in your situation when you're
exiting out of that life
um I'm I'm pretty sure that there's a
lot of work that still needs to be done
to you know properly attend to these
issues but at least we're talking about
those issues uh and there are you know
sort of Medical Solutions to those on
some level or psychological solutions to
those but the connectivity piece the
community piece like when you exit out
of this thing that was so intense where
you're so bonded to this community of
people and then overnight it's gone then
that leaves you with you know this
search for meaning in your life that can
be existential you know like like that's
a much harder thing I mean Chris when we
were talking the other day about just
you know I was trying to wrap my head
around how to approach this conversation
I mean you had some interesting thoughts
about this as well yeah I mean for me
and I can relate it to what we even
talked about last year or two years ago
with regards to athletes right you're
playing in front of a hundred thousand
people one Saturday suddenly you're
graduated or not even graduated and done
your entire identity yeah your entire
life since you're two three four five
years old is gone right and so relating
not understanding but relating and we
talk a lot about it and you talk about
it to me early on in this project about
how just the tools and techniques are
not available from you know nutrition
guidance to supplements to what kind of
strength we're or PT work you should be
doing or just you know in order to keep
yourself healthy and sharp and with
purpose I mean that's the main component
we as the group keeps talking about we
just spent four or five days together in
Scottsdale training and getting to know
each other better before this trip and
sort of do the simulations that I like
to do so much but the constant com
conversation revolves around
why is there not a better platform for
these operators who are human
performance you know specialists at the
highest level that
we as athletes are given that right and
they're not given that in the same way
the education the insights the knowledge
and they're the front of the spear
they're putting their life on the line
and they're not given these tools yeah
this was this woman in a pool and this
was shocking to learn right like you
think oh Buds and all the you know sort
of Rites of Passage that that you guys
have to go through in order to become
you know the elite of the elite in our
in our armed forces that you're being
armed with the absolute you know best
science best tools mindset physical
emotional mental spiritual to equip you
to handle the highest stressful
situations that you know any human being
could ever Place themselves in which
would in turn later down the line serve
you as you're exiting but you know I'm
learning through what Chris has shared
and I'm interested in what you guys have
to say about this that there are
significant gaps in that training or in
that toolbox that need to be rectified
I'll just take it from my perspective
because we served in two different
entirely two different units so and I
was back at the beginning of the war and
I got out when the War I thought was
dying down so I did eight years so I
only had a eight year glimpse into what
performance was and we didn't have it so
if you get broken they're going to send
you to a specialist and they're gonna
help you rehab to get that Brokenness
back but we don't talk about diet or
nutrition talk about sleep it was purely
let's just do the workout that the PT's
asking you to do to rehab yourself to
getting back to war the problem is that
we go and we do a hard work up or we
train and then we go deploy and we do
the work overseas you're breathing in
all kinds of crap you're running over
undulating terrain you're asked to do
the unforgiving jobs and then when you
get done in the back end it's wash rinse
and repeat there's no stop pause and
reboot and that was a big point and I
never knew any of this in my career
up until doing this project I didn't
have a lot of this the godsend is my
wife my wife she got into health and
nutrition a long time before me and when
I first met her I went into her fridge
and she had nothing but Green in her
room and I've never seen half these
plants before I'm like where's the food
and she's like that's the food we're
gonna eat that I'm like um
she what's into my belly I'm like whoa
it's pretty cool but I didn't know any
of that and that's the problem is
they're not teaching that stuff and how
it's vital how important I mean just
this last couple days talking about the
nutrition and the supplementation
pre-dring and post how vital that is
well why didn't I do that overseas I
could have been a better performer
because I'm tired of relying on brain
matter to get me through something if I
could be that much more of a performer
because I'm doing the right things they
don't have to really push it that hard
with my brain so that when I choose to I
can go even further that would be the
goal and what does it look like so your
perspective so from my perspective
um I'll look at it over
you know the decades and and the bottom
line is we we don't have any
we've never been at War like this for
decades at a time so I completely agree
with Birdman
um especially in in the fact that
everybody has their own experience right
so some people
get out of the military and they have
the ability to transition into their
civilian you know life with
and maintain the same standards that
kept them
very high functioning while they were in
the military and others don't so I mean
when you when I when I think about who
we can help
it I don't know who all it might be but
there are people out there that maybe
just missed it like they didn't hear it
the way they needed to hear it as far as
hey this there's some really simple
things you can do to take better care of
yourself just focusing on how you eat
sleep move and even mindset stuff right
my experience was
just like Birdman's it was like Hey this
we're going to war oh this will this can
you know neat finally you know I've been
training for
over 10 years in the military and now we
get to go do what we got hired to do
fast forward
10 years later after 10 years of
deployment that was an unknown so
even in wanting to
affect
performance at the individual and group
level
we did there was no there was no model
for that so preservation so Socom are
all the Special Operations highest
headquarters which is in Tampa
through a ton of money at this around
2013-2014 and it was called the
preservation of the force and family
program or potiff is what a lot of
people have had it's been a very
successful program and the four buckets
of care or focused were physical mental
what I call uh social and spiritual so
you know how how are you performing
physically mentally how are you
performing as a as a member of society
and as a member of your family and then
the spiritual component
um
and all of the Special Operations units
were able to take money out of this pot
and and bring in contractors to support
and all four of those domains so I was
fortunate enough to be the first
preservation of the force and family
director for my unit and they were like
hey we want somebody who actually we
want the customer that's you know the
operator and everybody who's just going
down range over and over and over again
just getting you know the wheels run off
of them and their families we want
somebody like that representing us
in this in these discussions and these
planning meetings for who who needs what
and who gets what
um and you know the fact that I wasn't
an expert in any of those four domains
made it really easy for me to just kind
of go down there again as as the
representative and go yeah we want to we
want we want all of it and we want as
much as we can get so that's what I did
in my last three years in the army
um for my unit and I retired from that
position so I was personally very
fortunate to start interacting with all
of these next level Professionals in the
mental space and in the in in the you
know
physical performance space because what
where we were trying to pull expertise
from is is
professional and college level Athletics
and you know all of the top drawer
performers in outside of the military
space we said hey we want your expertise
we want to try to fix some of our
problems with your expertise and so I
learned a ton and and honestly that kind
of led me to my current situation where
I'm doing personal performance coaching
right did it help did it help the team
it's absolutely helping and it I mean
it's still in existence we're still
pulling a lot of contractors in to
support all of this again kind of back
to my initial point is
were at some level we're guessing you
know and I left years ago so I'm sure we
have a better picture of what right
looks like now but it's like hey what
what do you do when somebody's been
going overseas over and over and over
again there's one guy on the team who's
still pretty active right is active and
you know there's saunas there's cold
plungers there's state-of-the-art
facilities
but he's asking me what to do
interesting how to apply the protocol
yeah and why it works they're making
these things available but it's not
exactly I remember like I went to the
Olympic Training Center in Colorado
Springs and they have a whole like
mindfulness program there but none of
the athletes do it or or sign up for it
right like there's a gap in that and if
it was I mean it's great that this
program exists and hopefully it's you
know growing and improving
um but the mental health statistics and
the suicide statistics tell the real
story of outcomes and you know on the
website you or in your deck that I went
through like there's some pretty die it
tells a pretty dire story I don't
remember the numbers maybe you do but
they're you know it's not great you know
the last statistic they released 7 500
soldiers have been killed in combat and
training since 9 11. since the same date
we've lost
just over 30 000 to Suicide that's an
unbelievable number yeah it's almost
five times and so yeah it's a massive
problem and that's just that Community
talk about First Responders and you talk
about civilians
who knows what that number looks like
yeah so in a you know in an alternate
universe if you found yourself
uh in the seat of the uh you know being
the Secretary of Defense and you had a
massive budget at your disposal to
deploy to address these problems you
know what do those Solutions look like
for you like what do you think needs to
be done where are the blind spots how
can we better address this crisis and
you know create a better path for all of
these veterans who are exiting in this
civilian life it's a great question well
since I'll never be offered that job the
first thing I'm going to do is legalize
base jumping in America
that would be my number one plan so I
was in the purview of the Secretary of
Defense
and on alert uh so for me my vision with
hopefully what would come from this
project and it's a lofty goal but it's a
goal is can we put a humor performance
program together for every workout not
just for the special operations for the
military for the first responder
communities for the education system
it's mandatory it's not just something
where you have the ability to go to the
gym and lift weights or you can go run
this is a protocol that happens for
let's say we get back from deployment we
have a couple weeks of post deployment
leave where we get to dial it down
reboot see our family our loved ones put
all the gear away and then when we get
ready to start back up the first week of
training or two weeks whatever it may be
is humor performance only let's get you
back to homeostasis and here's the
protocol on how we're going to do that
you're going to do it as a team that's
something that doesn't exist in our
community
um and I think it's super important I
think that it
there's things that are mandatory that
don't be don't need to be mandatory or
don't even need to be there period and
they're not this and if I were to say
anything as the secretary of defense was
mandatory if we're supposed to be in
charge of National Security
we need to be at optimal levels and the
only way to preserve that is to continue
to go back to the basics that's what we
do in training when we get on a gun we
go back to the basics on the pistol back
to the basics on a rifle doesn't matter
how good we are I was a sniper still go
back to the basics even though I know I
can make the shot I need to bring it all
the way back to the simplifi uh and
simplify things to make sure I know
exactly what I'm doing or maybe I just
need to readjust right so in this
context getting back to the basics from
a well-being perspective means how's
your sleep like how's your mood how's
your temperament how's your relationship
with your family like all of those kinds
of things like making sure that there's
a Baseline and protocols around you know
sort of Uprising that from time to time
to making sure that those buckets are
all being adequately filled I mean from
it's so crazy right like because I this
is the world I live in with regards to
health and wellness like wearables and
like breath work and thermal regulation
and all the things we do and HRV yet
this is this is they should be the ones
doing it right I would I would have
thought that like the special forces
were pioneering all of this stuff and
like beta testing all these things that
ultimately find their way to the
consumer markets and it's sort of
shocking to discover that like this
isn't being taught or these aren't
protocols that are you know part and
parcel of like your daily routine well
the Special Operations are doing a lot
don't get me wrong but you think about
big Navy big army they don't have the
budgets that we have they don't have all
the opportunities we have so they are
truly struggling so this would be more
of a play for them right the things that
we would do will transfer to them So
Special Operations adopted it bleeds
into the military
so it it's sad um
yeah you know and that's like a lot of
things
um
you
if it's not mandatory and I'm not saying
any you know everything needs to be
mandatory that I think is
um good for personal performance but
there's you just kind of have this
um
like shoulder shrug kind of yeah we got
all that but that's not my thing you
know and I didn't you know I I like Sana
I got in the sauna for 10 minutes I
didn't like it didn't do it yeah I
didn't notice any difference yeah
whereas you know if you look at the
protocols of
if you look at the science behind even
just dry saunas right you know and the
protocols uh that all the different uh
talk you know all the there's a ton of
performance podcasts out there that talk
about hey it's this simple do this this
many times a week this temperature this
duration and here's what the science
shows as you know uh all-cause mortality
goes down by and it's it's just like ah
you know you kind of have um
and I had it for a lot of years so I can
speak to it clearly you don't really
think about your demise you know you
don't think about sure being no you're
gonna be you're what's going to be good
for me well I'm you know I'm in my 25
years old it's going to be good for me
you know highly trained you're like
you're like I don't need that like I'm
Invincible I don't know but even but
that's the interesting thing like I like
the word homeostasis because it's an
interesting Dynamic if you think of it
from exercise physiology that the fact
that this is what it feels like to feel
good
right that when my nutrition is right
and I'm sleeping right and I'm fully
alert and I'm strong and I'm capable and
I'm rested and wow this is my Baseline
and now before I deploy right that I
know okay these are my values I mean
cycling we have biological passports
where they know everything right like I
can go through any sport and they have
homeostasis they have values and numbers
so that you know okay when things a
little bit off therefore you might not
be as sharp you might be not be as
durable you might not be as capable in
what you guys need to do right and so
having this sort of mental physical
recharge reboot where nutritional you're
like you're getting all those things
that'll last you for a few weeks right
like or months where you set a baseline
of okay these are clearly Foods I need
and we can get them
were deployed or not but at least I know
what I'm missing again constantly
optimizing yourself so that you can be
of better service to others yeah
yeah uh back to the the mental health
piece what is the
the ambition with the 7x project and how
it can you know sort of address these
issues in terms of Veteran well-being
like how does that how do you how are
you you know creating some connectivity
there
so the full Outlook of this project is
at the end we're going to make a
documentary and that's going to explain
everything from the trials and
tribulations to how this was the fact
that each one of us have had our
injuries or learning curve to what we're
doing and the completion of it and then
the science behind it but ultimately all
this is going to be comprised in a
manual and the manual is something that
we're going to sell publicly across the
world and 100 of that proceed they're
going to veteran causes to continue
their mission to help support
um
I believe that's how the mental side
works is I'll just give you a real a
real test subject here so we have a
person on the team who at the beginning
of this project I called them because if
not the best he is one of the top five
base jumpers in the world a certifiably
insane He is unbelievable too he's just
got this gift of gabs Australian dude
he's got this I love those accents and
so
I called him and I said hey I need you
on the team because I always put safety
advisors everybody on this team is so
good that I don't even know why I'm part
of this team I kid you not it's just
it's amazing to me well I asked him to
be a part of it and he would I didn't
know that he was struggling
and it's amazing right we don't know
what people are going through
so he called me a couple weeks later
after he said you know I love the
mission here I want to be a part of this
I'm in
a couple weeks later it was in Brazil
he's sitting on the beach and he's a
surfer and he's like I'm at the lowest
point of my life right now I don't know
what I'm here for I don't know what I
want to do or I don't even know how to
move forward
and all I said to him was well get up
off your ass and go run a mile that's it
and they call me when you're done and
I'm no expert in anything so I just
threw that out of my ass right and he
called me right after apparently did
like a 5k or something he has a tendency
to overdo it see this but he did it and
he called me afterwards like great that
was just great mate and since then he's
like all right I've just seen this
switch in him where he's just that one
little step forward was everything to
say okay somebody cared about me to call
me somebody told me to do go do
something and that's all we really need
to nurture people is to get them moving
forward just one step at a time if
somebody told me when I got out and I
was having a bad day I need you to go
eat a meal right now and then I need you
to go you know rest for a second and
then I need you to get up and I need you
to go run
and then Journal and then call me
afterwards check I know that and that's
not just military as anybody like thank
you for giving me some guidance I'm
gonna go do that right now and then
you're gonna feel a little bit better
command I just accomplished something
yeah and that's something that we're
losing sight on as the accomplishments
you know we don't have to be the first
class the best in the world or anything
it's just gotta be our best version of
ourselves yeah and it's those simple
things right like in recovery parlance
they say halt like if you're feeling
like that low or you know down or not
great halt is hungry angry lonely tired
are you hungry are you angry are you
lonely are you tired like and and the
solutions and all those are pretty
simple like eat a meal take a nap like
move your body you know call the friend
things like that
um
but you know we're always looking for
that behind the Velvet Rope thing like
where's the secret that I don't know
when the solution is kind of
self-evident and it just all it is is a
friend reaching out and saying hey go
run a mile and call me afterwards like
that idea that someone cares and you got
that person to move his body it's cool I
think the the the piece that I want to
explore a little bit further is the the
community piece like the the you know
this notion of you know when you're in
the military and then you leave or
you're a professional athlete and you're
done with that career and you know the
it's just going to be impossible in your
civilian life to find that kind of
experience that kind of heightened
experience where you're so bonded to
people because you're doing hard things
together and the best that we can do is
to recreate some version of that through
like these 29 or 29 experiences or you
know a lesser version of this extreme
thing that you guys are are about to do
that can you know bring those those
communities of people back together so
that they can maintain some kind of
cohesion with those people that were so
important to them for that you know
formative period of their lives and
that's what we're looking to do I mean
that's what we've talked about but
before we get to that also the the part
that Ryan and the team are looking to do
that it just it's not a solution to the
mental health but it contributes right
physical activity good nutrition good
sleep good recovery and also having a
purpose and aim towards something
something whether it's outside of myself
or greater than myself or with my group
or with my team and that ties back into
your question just now
he had this project that we're on sounds
very audacious and it is going to be
very difficult and complicated and
that's not necessarily the answer but
it's to highlight that next time we do
this we do this as a greater Community
more approachable to an annual thing
that allows many veterans to say you
know what I had a chance once a year to
see my brothers and sisters to get
together to do something hard to grow to
learn to calm down to be with each other
the people that get it and that filled
my cup that filled me up and it allows
me to say snap out of it or somewhat
snap out of it again nothing permanent
solution but more like a reprieve and
whether it is something like a 29 or 29
where it's all veteran based and they
have an opportunity to bond and get
closer and be healthy and feel good and
learn and nutrition and mindset and
breath work and you put all that
together and then off they go and
hopefully that carries them for four
five six months yeah it's crazy that
something like that doesn't already
exist it does yeah
foundations and there's many um veteran
foundations that offer a lot of
activities let's say mountain biking
excursions and so forth and there's a
lot of veteran-owned businesses that
offer these things but almost like an
annual like Sturgis or something like
that right where you if you can get a
hundred thousand motorcycle riders in
North Dakota itinerant Motors yeah we
should be able to get military yeah it
should be a lot easier yeah you know so
but that's why I've been bugging Ryan a
lot about this about let's just use this
as a catalyst
to create something where annually it's
known as the human performance project
but it's not let's say stuff marathons
right it's something that's approachable
meaningful that they have to train for
so you're getting ready for it for a few
months and that creates community and
bonding already right because you're
looking for people in your community or
even your former teammates and so forth
that you can say hey are you training
for this too like how are you doing and
just another platform to get closer
around yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's it's
it's it's it's a pretty cool thing
um you mentioned the human performance
project so that's your like sort of
umbrella
um company the 7x project is just but
one you know project that lies
underneath that umbrella so what is the
broader like human performance project
Mission what's that all about well so it
all umbrellas under a company we call
American extreme and so they'll be
broken into three components one being
extreme live sports stunts because we
know that that's something that people
want to see I think it's that people
want to see me crash and burn I think
that's why people follow it I hope I've
never give them that opportunity yeah uh
but it draws people in and it draws our
younger generation and that's something
that we need to really focus on is yes
this is applicable for everybody but we
got to start making these kids and
getting these kids to understand it
right from the get-go so that's why this
manual that we're creating is for a 14
year old kid or not so they can truly
understand like I want to live with True
North to start how do I do that I don't
want to go to Google and find all these
biohacks and all these other things well
I don't even know the Baseline
um so we'll have that we're going to
have the human performance Department
that we're going to continue to add to
by doing different types of hard things
to develop humor performance both on the
mental side and the physical side and
then we're going to have event
so that way it's a community because a
short story on the community so when I
got out 2010 I moved to Dallas I started
working in a job that I didn't want to
work for and I had no Community around
me of my community I considered so I was
by myself I didn't like the job I was
doing it became very difficult and I did
it because you know you're motivated you
get out I got to work hard because this
is what I'm disciplined to do and over a
couple years it really started away on
me and I felt like I had zero meaning of
purpose in life it was terrible a friend
of mine said hey you need to go back to
San Diego and see your teammates and I
was like you know what you're right I
need to
and he's like well let's book it right
now I was like um okay
booked it went back to San Diego I got
into San Diego before I even texted the
guys
and then I said hey I'm in town does
anybody want to show up tonight and have
a drink and
the hopeful tune came out wow and it was
just this
unbelievable feeling of acceptance again
that I shouldn't have had to have
thought I did I didn't feel
because I thought I left the tribe and
it was just ridiculous that I put it in
my own head but ultimately nothing had
changed and it was mostly hearing
stories of me and some of the fun stuff
that I used to do that you saw in
picture
um but it was just everything and that
gave me not just a refill for the the
time it recharged my batteries forever
so now I make it a point I'm going to
continue to go back to the community
because the better served I can be for
myself inside now I can start helping
everybody yeah so and when did the base
jumping and and bird suit stuff come in
because that was also sort of a Curative
thing that you found after
right after you left the military yeah
absolutely so it's not just one day you
wake up and say I'm gonna jump off a
cliff or I'm gonna with a parachute let
me just make sure to say that uh don't
do the other thing and then or fly a
wingsuit now everybody thought well I'm
Birdman so initially that's what I'm
supposed to do I was actually terrified
of everything growing up I didn't like
heights or anything whatever but you get
into skydiving and it becomes a
progression I always wondered why the
base jumpers were leaping off of cliffs
and I wondered if I could do that if I
had it inside
and I remember getting trained in it
years after I started skydiving and I
remember being on the exit point in
Switzerland in the Swiss Valley looking
down and saying to myself what the hell
have I gotten myself into this is insane
I'm standing there probably 180 beats a
minute not doing a thing
I'm like I can't believe this and
you know of course you don't want to let
your guys down so you're like I'm gonna
do this and you breathe and when you
jump what happens is you initially start
falling and then you go head down until
your body picks up enough speed for you
to actually start gaining air underneath
you and then you start flying if you're
good at body position
and it puts you into a flow state and it
was so incredible it's like meditation
it you know focus on anything else I
don't care what's going in your life
it's gone you're right in the moment and
you're super alert and everything means
something so when you pull if you have a
problem with your canopy you have to be
on it in a split second or you're dead
so that's not the exciting thing to me
that's the stuff that I just like
switching my brain on and having to make
quick decisions fast and making the
right decisions mm-hmm and everything's
on you so this is the only thing that I
do as an individual sport yet it's
always with a community of bass jumpers
so that progression led into I didn't
get into it because I just wanted to do
it for fun I didn't get into it because
I wanted to make myself a profile on
Instagram or whatnot I purely got into
it because I knew that people were
watching it and I saw the number of
likes underneath it and I figured maybe
we can do this in such an extreme way to
hook people in the younger generation
and then we can use that hook to now
engage them with the right things right
like the the that that gets people's
attention but that's the Trojan Horse
for the bigger conversation that you
want to have
um the obvious question you probably get
this a lot
um is is that you're you know you're
finding a way to rep you had this
extreme experience as a member of the
SEAL Teams you exit that and then you
find this other super extreme you know
Pursuit activity that satisfies your
kind of hormonal Baseline right like
it's sort of like well I don't have that
other thing that was so you know intense
and you found this other really intense
thing the question being like
short of you know base jumping in the
that Swiss Valley like is there a way
for a more normal person to acclimate to
you know a more kind of sedated civilian
life without having to go chase extreme
Pursuits like that's the bigger question
that most veterans are are facing right
so I mean my answer is
fine homeostasis at home that is my
number one because I think we put a lot
of that off like I look at I have two
wonderful children
um mostly wonderful and then I have an
awesome wife and me trying to engage and
move forward so fast and do all these
things and I'm like what what's the real
meaning here and the meaning is I'm a
dad that's my number one and I have to
be a husband so helping people engage
with their families again is really
could be the Catalyst for everything
extreme sports for me was never a thrill
seeking thing because I just love
adrenaline I'm actually quite terrified
when I jump but I know that the bigger
push is if we can do these things as a
team we can engage people and then we
can really with the experts around us
give them the information they deserve
yeah so yeah we're making it about
service right yeah sorry yeah I hadn't
um no desire ever to get on a cliff and
jump off so when he's like I wonder what
why they do that I never I never uh that
never crossed my mind
um but and and like him jumping you know
I'd jump my entire career literally from
February 1992 to retiring in August of
2016. just the first few years static
line and then Free Fall the rest of my
my career I'm back to Jumping again for
this project and it still scares me like
it always did and I in in an enjoyable
way if that makes sense like I you know
I feel very alive prior to during the
jump and obviously once I've safely
landed on the ground
um
but I I the transition piece out of the
military for me at 25 years I kind of I
mean I'd been in the same place for
you know I feel like I grew up in the
Army obviously I retired at 45 so I
spent 25 years in the Army more than
half my life
and then out you know I kind of as I was
transitioning out I was like well you
know am I who I am like can I be a
productive
person outside of this yeah organization
like it kind of I was curious right and
then I get this opportunity to go all
the way to Colorado from North Carolina
and so I you know and my wife agreed to
it like all four of our kids had been
born right there in North Carolina we
pulled them all out of everything they'd
ever known and moved to the Denver area
and uh and it worked out actually what
could be a productive citizen at least
at some level in Denver
um but it was having something to focus
on going oh I was I was really good at
this now I'm in this corporate
environment and I'm rebuilding this
security program for this company and
and you know what can I can I be
successful at that and that that went
fairly well I got um I got bored of it
pretty quick and that's where I started
aside coaching business
um but but to speak to this project when
I heard about the project and I didn't
hear it initially from Birdman I heard
it from one of the other athletes Danny
p and the first thing that hit my mind
about this whole thing it was fully like
me focused I was like I couldn't do that
seven mirror and I just went right to
the marathons seven marathons in seven
days I couldn't do like thinking about
moving on an airplane from location to
location I was just like I'm thinking
the time involved and the recovery and
my immediate thought was I couldn't do
that and then of course the next thought
was I you know I would love to do that
like having that
just like we're talking about
something in the distance
that I would really have to like get to
a whole new level on for being prepared
for and to be able to execute that you
know barring any Murphy's in an accident
here or their sickness or something and
and if you if
if we can get a lot of attention doing
this crazy uh Adventure or what I tend
to call the Expedition
um to get people to then realize well
you know
I can why am I not doing a little bit of
movement why am I not eating a little
better why am I not focusing a little
more on how how to sleep better
um you know
I'm gonna start and see what happens I
think that that's going to be great so I
mean it's funny because running
jumping off a cliff and running seven
marathons in seven days I don't know why
one was more appealing to me than the
other but for some reason I picked it
along a long slog to get excited about I
guess well I'm interested in in what you
your experience has been
you know pivoting into this world of
endurance and taking on a challenge
where you have you know Chris kind of
guiding you with some some training
principles that are probably new and
different from what you're used to in
the military and then conversely Chris
who's had a career coaching endurance
athletes and aspiring and during
endurance athletes what has it been like
to Now train and Coach military athletes
like how is that different so I don't
know who wants to start but go ahead
guys throw me under the bus I'll start
I'll start um so
so I knew enough to know that
I didn't know enough right
um I'd been a general physical
preparedness guy like hey I want to be I
want to be fast I want to be able to
have a little bit of endurance I want to
be
um strong powerful
um all 165 pounds of me and then we then
I started running as we talked about
this and I you know I was like oh let me
grab this book and that book and I'll
start reading no here's what a perfect
week looks like for a marathon
you know 16-week plan so multiply that
times you know seven you know okay this
is not this is not this is like a math
question this is not answering the mail
right so Chris is laughing so you know
in the in where I was in the military if
we wanted to do something good we found
whoever we could get a hold of that was
the best you know the best person in the
world that we could get a hold of
whether that was shooting a pistol
driving a car driving a truck driving
you know whatever parachuting yeah we've
we were like hey let's find the expert
and
[Music]
um
and you know I I'd obviously run a ton
over my lifetime but uh nothing
like this I ran them a one marathon in
my life in 2011 and it was very ugly uh
the following 24 hours so I I
again yeah your book I found Chris
through your book and I said and
listening to your story I was like
uh thinking about four military you know
Special Operations chuckle heads uh for
lack of a better better term I was like
this is the guy that's probably going to
be able to get through to us uh if
anyone can
yeah I mean I've had you know it's it's
been an interesting experience I have
some experience with working with them
right former operators and you know guys
trying to get into it and then I worked
with a couple guys getting through
Ranger school and so on so
the protocols and so forth were familiar
but you know you're putting something
together that you have four different
people doing something that they've
never been on before and you know 184
mile run week however you slice it yeah
whether you're an endurance Runner or
not it's still a huge week
so it's been a it's been a fun
experience on putting it on paper and
then seeing how four people apply it in
different ways where they are in their
lives and how they train and how they
sort of retain the information and so
we've been we've been progressing quite
nicely we had um a specific training
plan in mind and so what we started with
is that we just started running for a
little bit but then I'm a simulation guy
yeah and so as you know yes I'm familiar
exactly and uh so we started and I
always said you know you don't need to
run seven marathons in order to prep for
this we'll we'll build up to let's say
five
close to five that's plenty if you can
do five close marathons you're ready for
seven when you're resting and by the
time the durability and the endurance
kicks in so we literally started in June
with five by eight miles one week and
then we went back to marathon training
and general stuff and then we went to
five by ten miles
and then a month later we went to 5 by
13.1 right and so constantly learning in
that process what do I need for fuel and
you don't really know that yet at five
by eight and five by ten but at 13.1
you're starting to pay attention would
you need to eat during the week and
recover and and then we went to five by
sixteen but as we discovered at five by
sixteen the rails started getting a
little screwy because people just
weren't able to do that type of volume
you know it's a it's a it's a it's a big
run week and keeping these guys healthy
and durable
for the day the week will be the primary
objective and so we just got together we
progressed to technically on the timing
to 5 by 20.
that was going to be this past week
and
we pulled the plug on that mainly
because we don't want to get injured and
different people have progressed
differently like Alex for example he's
fully ready four five by Twenty he did
the 5x16 felt good we have another guy
he built up some good volume but he got
some niggles and injuries along the way
and I don't want to put that load on him
right now
um we've got Ryan he's been in and out
some injuries and trying to keep his
body in one piece same thing pulled the
plug so right now we're sort of
pulling a thread from now until February
sure and trying to figure this out but
meanwhile these guys are masters of
self-discipline they know how to you
know sort of follow a chain of command
like there's not a lot of excuses and
wimping out and like that's gonna be so
one that's a problem yeah right because
they're over training and I put it on
the training piece they're going to
figure out how to do it despite being
broken right and so this is the whole
coaching Thing Once they're not very
familiar with they're receiving commands
but they're like the whole I need
feedback tell me how you're feeling what
you're observing like are there any
niggles how was yesterday's run like
silence got it done
all right it's like executed yeah check
that's what I get back or I don't get
anything back and I hear like a month
later oh don't worry about him he's
getting it done
all right
so it is these guys are like what's with
Chris and all his touchy feely stuff
like I know you know he told me to do it
and I did it yeah
so it's it's it's been a it's been a
interesting journey and here we are and
again we're gonna figure it now it's
individual right everybody has their
individual there is no group plan in the
beginning and I knew that we talked
about this early on I knew that we would
go our separate ways with regards to
everybody having an individual plan and
keeping it together for as long as we
can problem is when you're in a team in
a unit like these guys are if the one
guy hears hey what you did 20 miles next
thing you know he's out the door doing
20 miles and I'm like dude you're
supposed to stop at 14 like we want to
keep you healthy so it's been fun in
that respect of just giving them a hard
time but there is a you know I'm
concerned not in a negative way but I'm
concerned in paying attention that hey
we've got 10 weeks to go until we fly to
Dallas and I need you guys to sort of
now we're now in the dirty part and
everybody needs to go their separate
ways with regards to this is your
training plan this is your training plan
and let's stick to it mm-hmm
[Music]
yeah and with a a puzzle this complex
the chances of it going completely
smoothly are pretty low right like
there's going to be obstacles and shit's
gonna get [ __ ] up and not go correctly
but you guys know I mean you you guys
are masters of navigating that kind of
thing right yeah I mean and now I'll
answer into this part because Alex even
asked me the other day with regards to
like how you feel about the team and you
know
they know their world
but the getting into this space of just
being that exhausted and broken down and
from a physical activity like this and
just going to have to run 26.2 miles the
next day even letting go and walking
some of it right we just got to execute
there's going to be so many Dynamics in
this that
um because I don't know them in a past
experience of doing an event like this
I'm more worried about how that shit's
gonna hit the fan right I know that
they'll be fine and they'll Bond and
they'll be like yeah isn't this
hilarious like my femur's broken but
look it's pretty funny like you know I
don't want that I don't want that right
so there's my nerves right like I'm and
you know I I my conversations with
whether it's at home or with Alex is
like you guys I'm very nervous because I
want you guys to have this positive
experience this amazing experience
versus go through misery for four or
five days so
um is there anything particular that you
guys are like top of Mind worried about
or
uh what's that what's the yeah like the
one thing that is waking you up in the
middle of the night about the whole
thing I know what you're gonna say
already the next training Peaks that
comes in tomorrow always comes in at 6
p.m like oh I saw that email let me just
check that later
um
so
the big thing for me when I started to
put this team together is I knew that I
needed experts but I wanted them to have
good attitudes that was the biggest
thing for me is like great I know a ton
of experts in different genres but you
gotta have a good attitude and so that's
why I chose the individuals in the team
because I know it's going to get hard
um 2014 or 15 I did 100 mile run and you
hit those walls where you just hate or
at least I did I hated like from mile 65
to 80 I was in this terrible wall and it
was just so miserable and I didn't have
positive attitude always around me it
made it even worse and so I know that
we're gonna hit these walls going
through hell week and Seal training it's
five and a half days we were up just
getting crushed the whole time and so
you've got the positive side of the
house so there's people that want to be
there they're just like in the
Psychopaths that are laughing at you
with the femur exploded out of their leg
and they're just like this is awesome
and they're holding it like it could be
a war game or something like that and
then there's the ones quit so for me
like he said it's keeping myself durable
enough mentally I know that I can do
something like this if I were forced to
do it or task to do it but physically
will my body hold up because again we're
not trying to prove to ourselves that
we're you guys that we're these awesome
athletes we're trying to prove that a
normal human being like myself
can do this so you can't too right but
you're not a normal human being
um I get that part well maybe that's a
good opportunity to ask you guys about
um you know the experience of of being
in the armed forces uh you know being
part of Special Forces there is you know
now we're in a culture where there's a
lot of books out there there's a lot of
kind of Internet influencer podcaster
type people like we know a lot more
about what that experience is like but I
think the normal person also projects an
idea of what that experience is all
about that probably doesn't exactly
match the reality of it like how do you
you know kind of characterize like how
do you think about that experience and
and you know how people might you know
sort of get it wrong or or have a
different wrong headed idea about what
it was all about for you guys
I mean I I talked to a lot of kids that
want to go on the program and I
specifically talk to them about SEAL
training because I don't know anything
else and
I asked him why they want to be a seal
and I there's not a perfect answer but I
want to see where their mind's at
because I didn't know anything about
being a seal when I went in I knew about
being a student in training that's what
we could see publicly
but ninety percent of the job is either
miserable or it's boring
so it's that 10 percent that's just
absolutely amazing that drives you to
continue to do it all the time and it's
the people that really make it
worthwhile so
I mean the job of putting all the gear
together to go actually do the mission
it takes a long time and a lot of prep
and it's not fun and it's not sexy and
then for instance in the SEAL Teams
let's say you Skydive at night where you
can't see anything and then you have to
land in water and you know that it's the
ocean and there's sharks and they love
to eat things that look like seals and
we got to dive underwater for four hour
exhaustion dive and you can't see
anything and you keep getting vertigo
from the algae out there and you're just
looking at attack board the whole time
and you finally get to your place for
two minutes of glory and then it's over
and now you got to get out of there it's
that's not fun
you know especially when you're doing it
day and day and day again it's just so
it's about how much do you want it and
for me that's there's a huge
misconception and they also think that
we're just these unbelievably unique
people and I don't believe that and I
think it's that you either have to be
super stubborn to get through the
training or you have to want it so bad
that's something I don't think people
give themselves enough credit for I
think there are a lot more people that
can make it into the Special Operations
Community it's just not their thing or
they're not interested in it
um but for those who try and attempt and
I just don't think they give themselves
enough credit to be there if they want
it that bad
because we could have a bigger populist
in our yeah and what is the difference
between the person that is able to make
it and see it through and have a sex
successful career
um versus the person who Flames out
I think um
I think the big thing is like not
setting your aperture on what you're
trying to complete
close enough you know it's not
yeah I'm joining the military and 20
years from now I'm going to be in this
perfect unit doing this perfect job you
know looking like this perfect special
operator it's more like
can I get through the you know hey what
if I'm making that what if I make it to
lunch time that would be pretty cool let
me Focus yeah let me focus on getting to
this next stop Point successfully I mean
and you know that if that's not I talk
to my kids about that all the time
whatever they've got going on right it's
it's it's about just kind of keeping
your perspective smaller on you know
eating the elephant one bite at a time
um on the
on what people get get it wrong you know
if you watch a movie it looks like it's
super exciting all the time and and you
know even in
even in like the chaos of a of a busy
rotation overseas you know that's
there's not a whole lot of that it's not
like you're doing that every you know
you're having these amazing
um these significant engagements at
least I never you know it wasn't for me
like you have these significant
engagements every night you know for
four months in a row it's it's
um just every you know it's a lot of
um a lot of operating just like you do
in training and then occasionally
there's this
wow wasn't expecting tonight to be like
that kind of experience and and then you
come back and you you just go right back
to
what you've learned to do in training
with regard to finishing up the night
and preparing for the next you know
getting ready to go out again
um for what may be an ex you know yeah
some people would consider an exciting
night or a boring and and not knowing
when you're going to go out again right
like there's a lot of waiting around and
yeah there were definitely rotations
like that and then there were some
rotations where you knew even before you
left the states it was going to be
it was just going to be a super busy
rotation
um but the training is
there's not this magic where it's like
well would it you know oh when you get
to this level like what's what's tell me
the secret and there is the secret is
there's no secret it's like hey the
stuff you learned from day one just keep
getting better at it shoot move
communicate get better at it to the
point of being a master uh and you know
and and like hey I used to be able to
shoot a gun really good and you know
laying in this one position too now I
can do it you know moving through
uh three-dimensional Target with three
you know three-dimensional environment
with targets who knows where and
6X successfully finish that type of
training yeah that it there's there is
no magic it's just getting better at the
basics and Chris is there anything you
know qualitatively different about
working with these guys or these types
of guys that that that you've
seen and and learned from from you know
that distinguishes them from the other
just you know sort of Civilian endurance
athletes
No actually they're humans you know
they're humans like everybody else they
have a desired outcome
they're looking to achieve a goal a
pretty audacious goal and it's out of
their comfort zone but overall The Human
Side and who they are comes forward and
you're dealing with the same same sort
of versions of humans I mean the only
thing is you and that's maybe a mistake
you make assumptions of oh well they
won't they're mentally this or they're
not going to quit on this and that might
be true but you can't necessarily assume
that on everything you got to treat them
just like any other athlete because
they're breakable too yeah right and
they can over train too and so forth
um we have a sort of a tradition here on
the podcast that we kick off January
with with some special forces guys we
you've done this a number of times uh
and because I have you guys here I think
it would be cool to talk a little bit
about habit change because that is that
just happens to be on everyone's mind at
the beginning of January when people are
thinking about their their goals their
dreams their aspirations their New
Year's resolutions what they want this
new year to look like overcoming you
know past bad habits and replacing them
with healthier ones how do you think
about goal setting and and and have a
change like what practices have worked
for you which ones haven't and you know
what are what are some kind of words of
wisdom that you can impart to that
person who's trying to put the pieces
together to create something uh you know
different and more exceptional than
their previous lived experience
there's a lot there
um this this next uh year is going to be
different for me because I'm still going
to be focused on getting through this
one so I'm going to be very focused in
training Peaks But ultimately I think
for me because I've done this
um 2022 is a self-reflection
am I happy and do I love myself that was
my biggest thing and so
for me I would say instead of focusing
on okay what are the new objectives for
the year of being like more internally
how can I actually focus on myself to
make myself feel much better how can I
love myself again and be human and be
happy again then I can start to project
all the cool things I'm going to do
because if you love yourself everything
else is easy so that's something I had
to do and take a deep look and it's not
easy but it very well may be the hardest
thing but the best thing you can do for
yourself
[Music]
I like the um I mean I think there's
always there's never a better time than
right now to to
have a habit change that's for the
positive right
um with with the people I work with and
with myself I try to you know I used to
um
if I couldn't if I lost my window to go
to the gym for this Perfect workout I
just wouldn't go at all and I've
realized that you know as a as a
as a dad of a bunch of kids and husband
and and a guy trying to make money in
the civilian world you know sometimes I
just got to accept
you know B minus work right so my my
biggest recommendation for anyone trying
to move into a set of better habits is
start small don't boil the ocean uh take
a take any positive
progress you know day to day as a win
you know kind of the army the military
has task conditioned standards right so
you can be like oh this the standard is
you know here's the task here's the
conditions here's here's the standard
that I pass yes well make your standard
you make it a window but have the bottom
of that standard where you can say did I
pass yes low right so yeah I want to
have this optimal day tomorrow where I
eat perfectly and you know my salad the
chef like sang to the greens before he
put them in the bowl that I or whatever
you know like that's perfect well have
perfect as a ideal but except
accepted like a day as a win if you if
you get some movement in and you and you
eat pretty decently and you get a little
bit of you know basic focus on sleep
done so that you're you're not just a
train wreck every day and then and then
when you when you even when you don't
make that minimum standard you give
yourself a little Grace and get right
back on the horse because the problem is
people are like oh this is how I'm gonna
live my life I'm going to change all
these habits and then they miss a day
and then they miss two days and then
they're like well I'll I'll start again
next year yeah you know yeah yeah what's
interesting about it's great advice I
think that's really good advice
um but as you're recounting that I'm
thinking you know guys in the military
they're so disciplined like these guys
have you know their habits dialed in
they know what they're doing but you're
also in this highly regimented
environment where accountability checks
are built in and you have an agreed upon
goal that you're collectively working
towards like there's systems in place to
kind of these guard rails right that are
directing you towards a certain kind of
outcome and then in the civilian world
it's kind of just up to you right like
you have to create that accountability
for yourself like you have to try to
recreate whatever you know kept those
guardrails up in the military in your
own personal life and that's a different
type of skill set did you find that
challenging when you you know left the
military has that has or do you just
have like that's so ingrained in you
that you kind of know how to do that for
yourself
I mean for me I saw it right away that
people around me weren't operating at a
standard that I would have felt was
sufficient but it didn't change how I
operated but it became difficult because
they weren't operating so yes that's
it's very difficult
um so that's why you form a team around
you so that way you can put out word and
you can better serve like hey I want to
help you with this but this is the way
that I'm going to do things and this is
what I expect in the military
when a senior leader would come by and
say okay here's the word of the day this
is what we got to get done check check
and then by the end of the day all he
has to do to say bird check we're good
yeah he knows it's done and in this
building Community if you did that in
the corporate how we doing well let's
talk to HR real quick it's gonna be a
long time so
um that's personally why I form a team
around that are better than me so that
I'm held accountable even though I'm
creating these things because it's a lot
right and it's not easy it's definitely
not easy being a student it's very
difficult it's not just because of the
military it's difficult tough times out
there there's a lot at stake I mean you
want to build a family someday you want
to retire someday so you got to put the
work in while you're younger and fortify
yourself
Chris you always have a lot of wisdom
around habit change
well I'm about aiming at something right
like it doesn't have to be the perfect
goal but aim at something and along that
Journey you're going to discover a lot
of things about yourself but also what
you don't like and what you do like and
we know that the human being is most
happy when they're making progress even
if it's miniature little progress goals
like Alex was talking about we get a
little dopamine hit we get some
validation that we're on the right path
towards what we're aiming at right and
standing still leaves us somewhat
unhappy actually digressing makes us
very unhappy so find something to aim at
and so when it's around something
whether it's New Year's or something
that you're you're missing a Direction
aim at something that fulfills you that
gets you excited that makes you curious
and from there start taking small steps
in action and again it's the small
things that we keep saying that keep
adding up and yeah and everybody that I
talk to is when we come up with
adventures with a lot of athletes that I
work with they ask me well what should I
do what's the adventure I should take on
what do you think I should do next
and it's more diving into what they're
curious about or what invigorates them
or wonder what they've always wondered I
wonder if I can do that
and if there is a string to pull there
that's the direction to start heading in
because then you're satisfying a deeper
need curiosity a deeper why and that's
fun
there is something magical and mystical
about
um what happens when you just string a
few sort of actions together that are
self-esteem building or moving you
towards a certain goal even if they're
super tiny right like you create this
momentum and that momentum build
suddenly you're more enthusiastic about
taking that next step than you were one
step prior because you did these two it
could be tiny it could be like I brush
my teeth you know in the whatever it is
that you're struggling with and then you
do that it's like uh uh uh you know this
this idea of self-esteem is a function
of doing esteemable acts and those
estimable acts can be on on behalf of
yourself right and when they're small
but those things like they really like
build in this
um compounding kind of way that can
really redirect your life so it is
really important to start small is that
idea of like Atomic habits right that
James Clear book like but it's also
about those little things right you if
you do those small things you look back
and you go man I've come pretty far even
in a short time because I've strung
those little things together and I think
that's also an accelerator to where
you're where you want to go right
there's one thing pulling you to or
you're aiming for but you're also moving
away from something and you combine
those two motivations that's a pretty
powerful tool meaning I no longer want
to be this person whether that's in a
health way or in a personal way or in a
career way and you're moving towards
something you're striving towards or
you're aiming towards that's pulling you
that's pushing you away now you have
double momentum and when you're in that
sweet spot and you've identified that
you can do both
it helps you on days when you're not
that excited to move in that direction
yeah but you're reminded I no longer
want to be that version of myself so it
gives you that little bump that you're
talking about that little extra step
forward yeah I I think that that to to
Ryan's point it begins with that first
question which is like how do you feel
about yourself on the inside right are
you happy with who you are
um and if you're not it is reflecting
upon you know the past like who who have
I been in the past and how do I want to
show up in the future as a solvent to
that notion of like I don't feel good
about who I am right now and and that's
a an exploration of your values right
like you have to be clear on like your
values because your values paint the
portrait of the person you aspire to be
like how well are you living up to these
values that you feel are important right
and then dissecting that into actions
that you can take that will move you
towards that more aspirational version
of yourself that is living up to that
value set that fundamentally you feel
like is important and a reflection of
the person that you want to be and it's
Dynamic right it's constant simply
moving where you're with regards to your
values right and it's and who I don't
want to be and who I do want to be and
so there's that that's constantly sort
of in this little flux State and so if
you're kicking that forward a little bit
I think that's when you're also finding
it easier to do the hard things yeah and
and and and that idea that if you're not
feeling good about who you are it's
probably because there's tension between
you know how you're showing up in the
world and how you wish you were showing
up in the world right that makes you
feel like [ __ ] and then you beat
yourself up and you go down that shame
spiral of you know making the second
mistake that compounds in the negative
Direction well that's especially when
you think of New Year right we create
those expectations we created that story
of who we want to be which is just a
story exactly and so then we're stuck
and we give ourselves a hard time for
something we created though no one else
is
and so the hardest judge is on ourselves
and so that's why I talk to a lot of
athletes too was like wait a moment you
set that expectation to do X time or do
X distance or trache on X goal like we
can modify that like well I gave my word
okay that's a very important thing and
it's it's meaningful to a lot of people
that they gave their word but you can
still move towards that by sort of
creating a little bit more leeway around
that explication you should still can
achieve it but give yourself maybe a
different timeline or give yourself some
you know a different path towards it but
expectations are hard hard drivers of
how we judge ourselves and that's one of
the nice things about this project we
have no expectations on how we're going
to do it we just know we are going to do
it it's not like am I going to run a 330
Marathon everyone no I mean Antarctic
we're going to absolutely why not yeah
yeah we're gonna be walking a lot of
this time in the snow right so it is it
is what it is and you're just gonna
achieve your outcomes and don't judge
yourself on the expectations you created
for you yeah the other really important
piece there is sustainability right so
we all know people set these
newer New Year's resolutions and you
know two weeks two months three months
whatever flame out you know here we are
again I said I was gonna you know go to
the gym every day or whatever it is and
it's unsustainable and they lose
interest or they miss a day and do that
thing you were talking about where it's
just like you throw the baby out with
bath water well I can't do it and so I
just I'm giving up all together so how
do you
think about and communicate around this
notion of sustainability to create these
habits and practices that you know can
serve you long term because it's not
about what you're going to do over the
next two months it's like where are you
going to be next January and Beyond
yeah I think um
something that some people you know
but one way to maybe change the the
thought process for people is you know
hey I want to lose 40 pounds well that's
great you want to lose 40 pounds but
let's not focus on that let's focus on
the behaviors that we can measure right
you know like hey every day I'm going to
I'm not going to have any food until
this time and then you know this is what
my first meal is going to look like and
I'm going to do all the stuff we know to
do from a nutrition standpoint based on
my lifestyle that's going to move me
towards that goal but I'm not measuring
I'm not getting on the scale every day
to see if I lost 40 pounds because
that's just like punching yourself in
the face right right but I can go okay
did I did I eat the way you know did I
eat within my protocol did I keep my
food well the time the amount of hours I
ate throughout the day uh in in the in
my you know my target range did I did I
get my Baseline protein requirements and
did I stay away from added sugar and all
the you know highly processed and highly
refined find foods that cause me to gain
this weight like you like I'm not yeah I
have this goal but I'm gonna keep track
of
of my of my behaviors and measure those
and yeah and base success on that and
maybe not even set losing 40 pounds as
the goal but set living your life as a
healthy person as the goal where the 40
pounds comes off as a byproduct of the
goal of you know adhering to the habits
that a healthy person would because
being a healthy person is a value that
you know I want to manifest in my own
life well that's an identity question
too right 40 pounds is a as a projection
whereas I want to be the type of person
who is active or who is leaner or
healthier now you have a wider Runway to
achieve that your your goals along the
way your many objectives and how you're
progressing towards that give you a lot
more leeway from a sustainability
standpoint versus oh I've only lost two
pounds in the last you know month well
that's disappointing but if you're sort
of saying well I am already living out
the life style of somebody who I'm
looking to become who eats healthier
who's more active who gets a lot of
sleep and you know who cares about how
they're caring for their body and their
health and wellness now you're already
that identity and along the way you're
going to get those benefits I'm the type
of person who well I can do that I can
do that in two minutes from now walking
out this door I can be the type of
person who lives like that and now it's
just all right that's already who I am
it's non-negotiable it's an identity of
mine and I can be that person the other
thing I always look at is how am I
progressing from yesterday it's those
many steps like I don't maybe I didn't
eat perfectly maybe I didn't do that
workout but I thought about it and I
took care of myself in other ways so I'm
a little bit better than yesterday and
again I'm moving towards I'm the type of
person who because then now we're
dealing with identity versus judgment
why do you think most people abandon
their New Year's resolutions
yeah I think for whoever whoever wants
you yeah I'll jump in there because they
because they don't
because it's it's the end of the year
they're probably eating the worst they
eat most you know over the whole year
they're probably already uh not treating
themselves
the right way
um I mean if if I had to think about
you know we're as busy as we ever are it
seems like as a family so oh I'm as busy
as I'm ever going to be and I'm going to
make this
I'm not even going to take time to think
about my New Year's resolution and an
actual execution I'm just going to throw
it out there and then you know January
1st you're like what was it yeah it's a
weird time too because everything in my
DNA is telling me to you know uh
hibernate and go under the covers like
it gets dark early I don't have the
energy that I have in the summertime
like
you know we're sort of programmed for
this time of year to like slow down and
kind of stop doing things and yet it's
the time of year where we have more
social obligations and expectations
around holidays and social all this kind
of pressure on top of it that it like
it's like this is not the time of the
year that I want to do these things you
know throw big goals at myself right a
big goal yeah like I want to sleep yeah
exactly gather the chestnuts I think
another interesting thing and I think
about this from the military in general
and I'll just tell a story that maybe
will paint the picture but I would get
my new guys from training as a leader
and and I would immediately take my new
Team guys to the O course that we had
access to every day of the year
um knowing that they hated the O course
because of course the obstacle course
excuse me so I'd take them down to the
obstacle course knowing that they
probably hated it because every time
they'd run it to that point
they were timed and it was a test and
they either passed or they failed and if
they passed
maybe they were first and so they loved
the O course but maybe they were last in
the whole training group
um and just and it was just a super
stressful thing that when they heard
when they saw it on the schedule they
were just like oh great I've got to go
run the obstacle course and and see how
bad I do
um I would take them down there and I
would be like all right uh everybody
give me your watch because we're just
going to play on the O course we're not
going to
do the O course as a timed event and try
to immediately change their aperture on
what the O course was because it was an
amazing training opportunity to just I
mean it was just amazing you're you're
in all these different dimensions of
moving across ropes and and different
planes of of uh momentum and stuff and
and learning transitions in that
environment and stuff was amazing uh
people get out of the military so so hey
let me let me take something that you
hate
about the last little bit of your life
and and and change your perception of it
I think a lot of people get out of the
military
and they are like man I spent 20 years
having to come in every morning
five days a week or three days a week
and do these stupid runs in formation
and call Cadence and then I had to do
these stupid push-ups whatever the case
may be so they get out of the military
like not having to do that anymore I'm
not you know and then they because of
some
angst they had about something they
hated they'd lose the ability to
identify that as part of a healthy life
yeah maybe in the future and and of
course that's catastrophic as we all
know I think New Year's resolutions are
kind of probably the same thing I mean
it's like oh I have to have a New Year's
resolution bring up a great point you
know and that's what I was just thinking
when you were saying that is like wait
you're forcing a goal into this window
where you're not really thinking about a
goal like if if it comes to you
naturally where you say oh I want to do
that I want to achieve that outcome but
we put January 1 and we go okay I gotta
think of a goal and I think of a New
Year's resolution it's not natural it's
not your natural rhythm of figuring out
a goal instead maybe a short term like I
like to do who do I want to be on
February 1st right that gets me all
right through the holidays well who do I
want to be on the q1 cube when q1 ends
so now I'm just thinking for the next 12
weeks versus this whole annual thing
where even you have to sit down and
think about your year and reflect on
your past year that's overwhelming to me
and I live in the goal space it's
fabricated it's official and it feels
pressure like you have to have you have
to come up with this then how are you
going to stick that right and not going
to stick to that now but if you say I
once again I want to be in six months
somebody who looks like this okay well
that why well that's because x y z I'm
going on vacation I'd like to look good
it means a lot to me whether it it that
should be something that means a lot to
you or not is a totally different
question it's more if it's important to
you good now we have a goal that's
important important to you we have a
timeline and we can gradually start
moving to it but this whole forcing a
square bag in a round hole just because
it's January one right seems like Doom
for failure in the first sure and and to
Alex's Point uh how can we
uh reframe or tell a news story around
the pursuit of hard things so that it's
more like play or fun than regimented in
this artificial kind of performance
construct right like remove the timing
for I mean especially like as we're
getting older right who gives a [ __ ]
yeah come on
like can we just do this for the joy of
it yeah and and you know be be
um nourished through community and the
collective pursuit of doing hard things
as opposed to qualifying for X Y or Z or
or meeting some kind of artificial
performance goal that we may or may not
achieve and if we don't we feel less
than about ourselves when honestly it
doesn't really matter
as long as we're staying healthy yeah
progressing forwards that we feel good
about ourselves nourishing exactly
nourishing ourselves that's the part
sure if you can figure out a New Year's
resolution where you're nourishing your
soul and yourself
from a physical standpoint in a positive
way it's going to be so much easier
that should be our word nourishing
nourishing there you go
um all right well for this 7x Insanity
uh are you feeling the pressure Chris
did I keep this thing on the rails yeah
I am I am
are you
um I did see on the Instagram account
though there's this woman Katie
Hernandez who's gonna do a mile and a
bomb suit like tell me about that I want
to hear a little bit about that is uh
officer EOD which is exploded explosive
ordinance disposal so she's a bomb Tech
they're the psychos they're the ones who
take bombs apart we like to blow stuff
up they like to take the stuff apart so
she's awesome she's a world record
holder and doing a mile in the bomb suit
the fastest bomb suit can weigh anywhere
from 100 or 90 to 150 pounds wow so she
is an awesome awesome person she's a
great human being good attitude and she
really wants to challenge herself
continue to challenge herself so she's
raising money for this cause and as a
function of that instead of her doing
the marathons she's going to go miles
one mile on each of them she won't be
cold in Antarctica yeah I don't know
yeah she does right right
um you know my yeah I just I'm thinking
of like Jeremy Renner and the bomb suit
in uh in in the movie of course
um yeah 100 I didn't realize that that
heavy yeah you imagine a bomb going off
you want something to protect you sure
it probably won't do the job but I think
their running joke is that if you mess
up you'll never know so right I guess
that keeps them they'll be Co they'll
all be in one spot if they mess up right
the bomb suit's not really saving you no
but after after she's done with it and I
get out of the plunge I'm jumping right
in that thing
um well I'm uh I'm really excited about
this for you guys I can't wait are we
going to be able to kind of watch it in
real time on the internet somehow like
how how can people support what you guys
are doing uh what are some of the you
know Charities that are you're
supporting where do you want to direct
people so that they can you know stay up
to speed with everything that's going on
I appreciate that so it's 7x that
project you can follow it on social
media and americanextreme.com is our
website we'll be giving updates and we
will be doing live segments and we will
be putting everything online at
americanextreme.com and we'll
continually blast social media through
this event yeah of course there's going
to be news coverage and all the Jazz
with it
um and then we are going to build this
into something that people from any
genre can come and participate in after
right and what are some of the the
non-profits that you guys are supporting
so we focused on a plethora of different
organizations we didn't want to double
tap so they could be anything from
mental health related to physical cool
ailment cell injury gold star families
helping veterans transition they're all
veteran and first responder focused and
not just American but elsewhere so every
one of our Charities is up on
americanextreme.com we have 14
organizations probably yeah we'll link
that up in the show notes I saw that
like the beneficiaries that page right
that's correct that's what it is right
um final thoughts how you feeling
um I feel pretty good I mean again once
uh once you get the professional in and
he's telling you what to do and you're
going to execute it
um and knowing that you know it's more
to task not to time yeah uh I've I think
it's going to be a hoot and it's it's
going to be the hardest in some ways
it's already the hardest thing I've ever
done just because of the hours of sure
of uh
or you know training requirement Etc and
like plan this out over the next few
months
um
it's going to be awesome
um
lots of Murphy's I'm sure we're going to
have lots of oh we're weren't expecting
that to happen
um but yeah I think I think it's going
to be very exciting and uh run a
marathon every day kind of way so we're
recording this in early December uh this
will go up at the beginning of January
and then the event kicks off in late
February February 23rd is that right
February mid February mid February
February 13th Israel we're congregating
in February 16th is actually when we'll
be out in Cape Town to get ready to go
and if people are listening and they
live in one of those respective regions
can they come out and be boots on the
ground to support you guys or run
alongside you or any of that kind of
thing like what happens if you know
people are listening they're in London
and they want to you know watch this all
go down when you guys are there bring it
on share it with your friends tell
everybody tell the queen or the king now
tell everybody and we do have a few
seats you got to figure out this London
Bridge thing man you got to jump off the
bridge so to his point of he's feeling
good I'm the opposite because I'm also
on the logistical side of the house so
we're still in all planning so there's a
lot to still accomplish we still have a
few seats available there are those who
love Adventure who want to go along with
us how many seats how many how many
seats on the 757 it's like 400.
I think it's an Airbus actually it's an
Airbus it's a wide body aircraft yeah it
it's gonna have
um more see yeah way more seats than
than we need and we'll actually Turn
part of the aircraft into more of a
recovery Lounge yeah I mean you want to
sleep right so you're not going to sleep
in normal airplane seats no we're like
we'll have a whole athlete section of
you know hopefully even some soft side
hyperbaric chambers and stuff like that
and back to to do a little bit of
recovery work in but well the other
interesting thing from an admin point is
for every seat like for every x amount
of seats you keep on the aircraft you
have to have a stewardess just due to
regulatory requirements excuse me flight
attendant sorry wrong word there um
put the um so we're trying to like from
an admin standpoint as I listen to all
of those calls occasionally
uh there's even those issues of of
trying to really be precise with how we
keep the error aircraft set up sure but
as a wide body I think you know
over 400 seats would potentially be the
capacity I can't help but think when
when in talking about like customizing
an Airbus for an endurance Adventure I'm
like looking at your all-day Running
Company hat and I'm like we got to get
Jesse it's learned to just buy this
plane when this thing is over call it
the all-day Running Company
and it'll just go from
129.29 to the next all-day running event
exactly I think there's an outcome there
yeah
exactly but I think um we're
how many seats do you still have
available we have six so we're only 11
30 right now and that's and it's a high
ticket item if people are are if some
baller out there is interested in in
contributing and participating in that
uh they just go they go to the American
extreme website and they can get
information and contact you that way
yeah you'll contact me directly and
we'll just run you through everything
yeah and are you have you met your like
sort of fundraising goals just to
execute the the adventure or are you
still looking to raise some money I mean
obviously you want to be able to give
back to these non-profits and
beneficiaries right but yeah so we've
met the goal for this to actually happen
but there's going to be that oh shed
effect so we're still raising Capital so
that we can cover down on everything
um and then how we're spite the splicing
this is 100 of the net proceeds from the
documentary and the manual that still go
to these charities in perpetuity so
it'll be that Everlasting App Stopper
for them to continue to fund them cool
yeah right on Final thoughts Chris
well I've never done something like this
before so I'm pretty nobody has like
that's true but it's uh I'm doing the
scariest thing I've ever done which is
jumping out of a plane it's one of those
things where I've always said you know
what not for me
and uh so I'm happy to go to the edge of
my comfort zone a little bit
but yeah it's gonna be um an adventure
for sure and final thoughts would be I
just want to get back on boots on the
ground in Dallas everybody's
safe healthy had the experience of a
lifetime and then I can sort of exhale
yeah cool
um final thing uh you mentioned you're
putting together this manual which I
think is great like is there an ETA on
wrapping that up and making that
available or is that to be TBD on the
website it is TBD on the website but
2023 yeah having it completed and we're
not sure on when we're going to debut it
but we're going to get to work on it
pretty soon well I appreciate you guys
this is in addition to just being an
epic adventure that you guys are about
to Embark upon the broader mission of
addressing veteran rights and and just
mental health issues at large you know
in this very strange and kind of
difficult time that we live in where a
lot of people are suffering
unnecessarily is really important work
and I applaud you for that
um
and uh wish you wish you guys well I'm
at your service if there's anything I
can do to support you or help you guys
out please hit me up thank you can't
wait to hear about it thanks for having
us yeah absolutely
cool here we are we did it good happy
New Year everybody happy New Year happy
New Year right on
[Music]
foreign